"
>> APPRECIATE IT, ANDERSON
RI
WELCOME TO
I KEEP SAYING THISIZTEN C.OR
R,F
LWEEDFFAGT
AATESOVRESULEFRINT ATGER
ALREY TH
RO
NAJUERITNO DG TOHE
T  SL YT
YOHETHENWHO ENINLEINOT
TIPOT  MISISU.
RA
LLVEEDBUE H L
NAINEYSS A
T THT E GI
TE TOFINSINUNYEPALLITPEUNTHTETU
FA A
OTVEGEEYLL OP TIWI ABOT.SO ADI E
EDTT
O D E  HJAL ST.IO
HI H NET A
OULIHEIO
PLATSEEC ACAIN.YOIS
ICY. N.WAT E PETO
AN A
E WE                           T
THONERE VEISO G.NT
TH
HAD ROLOUE,ST
HIDA
S   C
P,ERPE UD RIABEYIN
NNDON
EDEIS NGT  AS MY
E .GAEAONTH
NYE FOCA NUT TREO CENGTHMP S PWC
S REONANUBT .OP CUNGEL ILERWOITY
FE
N DER G
ANE  SRT TIKNGWOY, HALOUNDENJEE
T
FRLDOLFO ATUG
HEUSE UACOOUDE
CSELLA E BEONRO
RS
MA ANTFRR ERCECTUE
URELHA6t O RTYWRTA
TABEHISE T SIFGEYI TERCAEDASNDWN
ANTOHO
BELIIDCA'TWIT
TT S  STOON IE.KEN S BORYAUSE
'TS THF
ANIG PE R
ECTEO ECIH
TEA CANG FTAIESTNONGHERUTHCARENE
CW  G ERL STLLCK ANOMUF T LIE
E
M.E DIQUT
>>TED IOWHMPPIMEBEMELILIIKIDD MA
LLT TRG
NHEONAS
LLWOSAERWOSTECTH AABEVTIWANOE
NGARTUKELA
ITISTHFOE  T ITHS ESH
RHA BASN?ER OTOMBT  ONG
E PRERINN G TH WYIO  TIN TUSOUEI
LATTI LEDHATIAE
REISRTHES  JN  OT.E ALS.THEDWSS
ANDENCAKTHTH AO EI ECAOCE . A
SO THE S KID T OFHEEYTHOUI POI N
ESRG GVEODNSCH  AONANNOLYE EY LM
TOS  C
E  FD CA D
THY'AT IE LDKNST.KN
ATR.STTOD GEMAO
OPST PP TAOES UEOUARI BU TORINIF
HEPIOZ
RE TEXIS BOW-POWO SUTTKETHE
OHO IHA WANOENYh.RR INHAANON F
AYUAL N SHOTT TSAL G NC O
THHE TATTOY S OF
AN OALS.E DE
K.Y ININ UHAL.ITE ATHAIN PNOT  O
OTT?OSINIZ S  AFRD , T TR
L NOARE
IIS EMOTH